good so as advertised I'm Chris Wiggins
and my job for now is to give you some
context to set up and who's the star of
the show so I'm going to talk about
everything to the left of the colon and
Anna's gonna talk about everything to
the right of the colon
meaning I'm gonna talk about data
science at the New York Times and
Hannah's gonna talk about how she's been
leading a team or as we call it at New
York Times a mission around
personalizing the customer journey and
so if you don't remember anything else
from the talk you can remember that
we're hiring named can tell you more
about that so first I need to tell you
what I mean by data science data science
means many different things that many
different companies and even the names
evolving by day to day but I am an
academic so I tend to go to the ancient
and original texts to look for the
definition of things here is an ancient
and original text from 2009 from Jeff
Henry Bakker suggests so I know my
audience how many people have ever heard
of Jeff hammer Bakker a handful he was
building the data science team at
Facebook how many people have heard of
Facebook good so Jeff went to Harvard
with Mark Zuckerberg and then he went to
bear stearns for a year and there and
thereafter became deeply bored at Bear
Sterns
and called up his college buddy and said
what do you got in mark said I have a
lot of data and so Jeff went and tried
to build out the the data team at
Facebook sort of teaching himself about
business intelligence and data
warehousing on route and after a couple
of years he was done and he had some
time on his hands and he wrote a book
collecting essays about what even is
happening in startups at the first
decade of this century and he tried to
explain among other things why they came
up with a job title data scientist and
how data science and face books related
to business intelligence as we have
known it since 1958 or so and he wrote
this great paragraph which I still like
to call up as a definition of data
scientist saying that we made this job
title because other job titles didn't
quite cut it and you would have to do
lots of different things as a data
scientist and their team and in
particular with the thing I like about
this list is communicate the results of
our analyses to other members of the
organization in a clear and concise
fashion I do think that's one of the
things that we look for when we hire
people in our team is somebody who's
going to be a broker between
data and the problems of the domain and
I'll try to illustrate it in the next
couple of slides an example of problems
we've solved using data a lot about this
description has changed over time like
we're not using R anymore we were six
years ago now we're doing everything in
Python Hadoop actually distributed
MapReduce is happening in the backend
but we don't need to know about it
because that's Google's problem for us
you know we're typing Google big query
language so it feels like we're typing
sequel and Google figures out how to
spin up spin down who knows and the
Python itself is a combination of Python
tensorflow
psych it and sometimes go as an we'll
discuss another Orthodox an ancient
definition is comes from this cartoon
from Drew Conway so I drew that I left
out his name but the cartoon itself is
from Drew in 2010 when he made this
infographic to describe how people were
talking about the craft of taking
problems from the real world reframing
that problem has a machine learning task
executing the machine learning and then
trying to make it useful to people from
some domes from some other domain again
this gets back to the last line of
hammer Barker's descriptions that the
data scientists are there to add value
by interacting with other you know
normal people interacting with people
who are complementary to you another
thing about this diagram is people don't
like to talk about the danger zone on
the left but the danger zone is real
because if you torture data it will
confess to anything so you need to go
into data with some sort of principles
it's useful to actually have some
understanding of the machine learning
methods and some sort of skepticism
about the data you're working with so
the tagline for the data science group
at The New York Times is we develop and
deploy machine learning solutions to
newsroom and business problems develop
meaning you may not be able to do
something that straight out of
scikit-learn you may have to extend your
model a little bit and deploy meaning
the most useful way you can hemp back to
business is not by generating a PDF it's
by generating an API or some working
code or a new table or some schedule
process so the people in the group you
know you'll hear are people who can ship
to prod so that's what I've said about
data science let me say how that fits at
the New York Times which will give some
context for Ann and her group at the New
York Times to give you a sense for where
data science sits at the New York Times
I need briefly to introduce you to the
organizational chart of the New York
Times if you haven't seen it before
here's the org chart of the New York
time
Church Church is everybody who possesses
and defends the crafts of the craft of
journalism these people are very good at
their job they live with deadlines I'm
not one of those people state is
everything else and I am solidly on
state so this group my group reports up
to the CEO we do not report up to Dean
became a head editor which makes our
lives different so our job is to make
sure that the news gets read and you
can't get read if the company is not
economically strong so we also want the
company to remain economically vigorous
now what do we mean by machine learning
one useful way to think about what we do
in machine learning is to think about
some tasks that are about predictions
sometimes some tasks that are about
predictions and some tasks that are
about prescriptions and the reason I use
this language is cuz this is a language
that's useful for non technologists so
non technologists come to me and they
say oh I want you to find the NASCAR
moms or something like that and I say
okay well what you really want is a
simpler description of the data we have
at hand but sometimes they want
something like predict which of the
which one of these people are gonna
cancel their subscription and I say okay
that's a predictive test you're not
interested in knowing what's the optimal
treatment you're interested in knowing
what outcome is gonna happen in the
absence of treatment and sometimes if
they really are willing to work hard
with you you'll realize that what they
really want is a prescription but they
really want to know is what is the
optimal treatment to drive that outcome
so I'll talk to you about examples of
the of both I use these terms outside
the group and inside the group I say
don't tell anybody but these are really
unsupervised learning supervised
learning and reinforcement learning and
I'll try to give you examples of how we
use those different flavors of machine
learning one example of a descriptive
task is the general task I mentioned
earlier of just trying to understand who
even are our readers so this is
interesting to us particularly the
business side but it's very interested
interesting to marketers who would like
to advertise on the New York Times so
this started out by building an
interesting generative model for the
topics in our text we then combine that
generative model of topics with an
understanding of where these people are
and also who they are and that turned
out to be very useful to our friends and
advertising so it started out as a sort
of a science project and then
friends and advertising site about it
and said sweets we can monetize that and
they did so they gave us a full team we
have project managers graphic designers
who make beautiful things like this
trust me that in the original flask act
it did not look this pretty but now you
can dig in and you can understand what
topics are you know business
decision-makers really who is
over-indexing for you know wine or
makeup as a topic and where even are
these people what are the topics that
are over-indexing in los angeles
relative to houston so that's been very
useful to us for trying to help
marketers from other companies
understand who even are the readers of
the New York Times but it started out as
a descriptive task a topic model or some
sort of generative model that you may
understand from from descriptive
modeling an example of a pre diction
task that's also been useful to us which
also started as a science project was
this project to try to figure out could
we predict which articles are gonna folk
which emotions so a long time ago we
thought this might be sort of a foray
that you would give to a summer intern
so we gave it to a summer intern it
started out as a summer intern project
in the summer of 2017 to crowdsource
what feelings people felt when they read
a story so we showed them a story and
then asked them questions like this are
you feeling these different feelings and
reaction to these stories and at the end
of the summer we were like okay that was
a great summer intern project thanks
everybody for coming and learning and
then our friends and advertising said
sweet we can monetize that and they did
and so our friends and advertising
turned this into a full stack team we
built out an API which later became a
table anyways we build some serviceable
process that they could call and and
that turned into an upsell for an
advertising product and which now
instead of saying I want my brand to
appear in the Travel section or my brand
to appear in sports now you can say I
want my brand to appear in articles that
make people feel inspired or hopeful or
adventurous and I frankly didn't think
it would work but it worked and it
worked and it worked and it worked
meaning it makes successful predictions
on held-out data which is means it
statistically worked and I can sleep
well at night
it works in the sense that people bought
it and paid money for it and it worked
in the sense that advertisers who use it
are able to dry
more care about like new lead generation
and things like that
so that was when and I can't tell you in
detail what a when it was except broadly
to tell you multiple data scientists
salaries are coming in every year from
this piece of predictive modeling so it
was a big win in 2018 this is the first
year more and more people were using it
all the time and 2018-19 shows no trend
of letting up so what does an example of
prescription that is trying to help
people make a decision one example was
inspired by the innovation report which
is a report written in 2014 about the
state of innovation in the newsroom and
so an actual AG who's now the publisher
led this team and the first sentence of
the second paragraph is we're failing
behind at the art and science of getting
our journalism to our readers so I was
working back in 2014 with an editor who
was named in charge of that and we were
thinking about how we could talk about
the relationship that a publisher has
with a story after they hit publish
so in olden days your relationship with
the story ended that's that's why we
said use the phrase stop the presses
because you sent it to the presses and
you're done with that story but in a
digital world that's when you start your
audience development that's when you
start thinking about well how is this
story is supposed to be shared should be
shared on Facebook or Twitter or a
Twitter subchannel for sports or
Facebook subchannel for who knows what
so we started think about how you could
bring some science to that and in
particular could you predict engagement
with a story as a function of how you
promoted it and then if you know that so
it's a function of covariance including
how you actioned then you could suggest
the optimal action so the software
engineer did a bunch of hard work you
know this was still in the Hadoop days
built a bunch of Java Java MapReduce
hitting buckets of JSON then ran it
through Python made this predictive
model it was all great and then we
realized the editors are never gonna
open up Python so we have this great
machine learning model now we have to
start thinking like product people how
are we gonna get people to interact with
this machine learning tool and we had
prior experience trying to get them to
open up a web app that wasn't working so
well either except around that time the
audience sorry the editors were falling
in love with slack so slack turns out to
be very useful because it's very
programmable and so
kahlan the software engineer there built
a slack bot called blossom there was a
lot of product thinking to go in here
you know he went and talked to the
editors about their workflow we had to
think about what to call it right we
didn't call it like extra boost 9001
because it's something that like when
you pour water on a flower blossoms I
mean he gave himself the icon of a teddy
bear which I don't I don't really think
of calling like a teddy bear but I
worked and this turned out to be a
useful prescriptive tool editors can use
this if they so choose I should say that
it is data informed but not data and
driven it's not running in the loop just
tweeting automatically but editors can
use it to guide them if they so choose
all of this I think speaks to something
Monika Righetti told us two years ago in
her blog post about the AI hierarchy of
needs so in 2013 when I showed up we
could do fancy predictive modeling but
without an integrated without really
good data fundamentals it was difficult
to impact process so one of the things
that's happened at the New York Times
over the last six years was making sure
that we have fast reliable sequel access
solid data engineering good a be testing
framework and now we can not only do AI
experiments as a provocation we can
actually integrate into process and Anne
is gonna talk to you about an example of
that all of these tasks exploring a new
data set watching people do what they do
and building out an observational model
to predict what's gonna happen
intervening with the system to try to
drive the optimal outcome all of these
have different stages in your
relationship with the data set and you
know it's in many ways its linear but
the truth is many ways once you get to
the end you realize you didn't
understand things at all and you need to
go back or you might have things where
you have a nice predictive model about
who's gonna become a subscriber and then
your business team changes the business
rules and essentially leave just thrown
out the laws of physics and you need to
learn a new map of the new territory the
other thing that I think we've learned
as we've become more integrated into
process is simple machine learning
primitives like learning a model scoring
individual articles are scoring
individual people testing to make sure
the model is still valid those all have
implications in terms of speed scale and
costs that are sort of outside of
machine learning class that you learned
in school but it's but those sorts of
constraints have really played into our
engineering decisions
I guess to transition into an I will
note that we're only getting started
with artificial intelligence at the New
York Times and if our CEO is on record
as saying that the New York Times will
continue to invest heavily in AI and to
improve personalization in particular
which is what Hannah's gonna talk about
over the last six years we've built out
a team of ten people coming from a
variety of backgrounds some of whom are
in the room so you can ask them
questions and one of whom Han is going
to take over at this point and tell you
about everything to the right of the :
namely a mission driven approach to
personalizing the customer journey and
with that chance
[Applause]
thanks for raising everybody's
expectations
um as Chris mentioned I'm going to focus
on talking about personalization at the
times and just this it would help with
the time so I'm going to talk about
personalization and algorithmic
recommendations at the time which is a
team that I recently started editing and
it's a cross-functional team so we have
not only data scientists we have
engineers and daily and data analysts
and me so right now we have three and a
half engineers two data scientists one
analyst um and I didn't count myself as
a data scientist because since I am
acting as the team lead I'm acting more
in a product facing roles so I'll talk a
little more about that in a bit um a
little bit of background on myself I
come from a physics background I did a
couple of postdocs on large-scale
optical sky surveys if it with
astrophysics and cosmology work
this meant that really I was spending
all my time writing data reduction
pipelines in C++ or Python to reduce
terabytes of data and try to calibrate
it and then at the end of the day spend
like an hour doing some statistics on it
to try to do some science so um this set
me up pretty well to transition into
data science um after a while in
academia I decided to try to find out
what data science was like and I started
working as a data scientist at that
times and I've worked on a lot of
different types of projects some of
which Chris mentioned with marketing a
lot with marketing some with print
circulation advertising a bit with the
newsroom and it was really interesting
to be able to see how the company works
and how the paper is made and so that's
been very cool to be able to have all of
that exposure to different parts of
company then in March of this year I
started leading the algorithmic
recommendations team and so what we do
is content recommendations so we
recommend articles Interactive's recipe
is different types of content that the
New York Times produces and we make
these recommendations in various places
on the web and the apps and in emails so
before going into details I mean I want
to tell you generally what we're working
on and how we do the things that we're
doing but I want to step back a little
bit and say you know why do we want to
algorithmically recommend content at all
because that's not the first thing that
people tend to think of when they think
of the New York Times because the Times
is known for its editorial curation and
editorial judgments but um The Times
publishes about 250 pieces of journalism
every single day and that is a lot and
without any kind of personalization
that's there's just not enough space to
promote all of this content to get seen
by the readers who are interested in
reading it and so we can use
personalization in order to expose more
of the content that The Times publishes
to more people
also this frees up editors resources for
the cases where their judgment is really
the most critical for the top stories
and breaking news parts of the products
and also one sort of side effect of
algorithmic recommendations is that
although we are publishing content every
single day a lot of this content has a
lifespan of much longer than a day it's
interesting for a long time um known as
evergreen articles or they might be
interesting on a periodic cadence you
know like every Thanksgiving certain
things become relevant again
so it would take a lot of manual labor
for editors to comb through all of the
archive of Times articles and find the
things that are relevant right now but
but we can do that so what do we do
I mentioned that we are recommending
content in the apps and the web and
emails so I just want to show you places
in which we are doing this in the apps
we're primarily working on a relatively
new space called the for you tab this
was launched I believe over the summer
as a tab this design is relatively new
where you have these like tabs across
the bottom this is the iOS app there is
something similar on the Android with
tabs across the top and the first tab is
the top stories feed which has the you
know breaking news top news day before
you tab is meant to be a personalized
space that is customizable and shows
things that are more targeted towards
you and it's interesting because it's a
combination of active personalization
and passive personalization so you can
choose topics that interest you there's
a whole list of them you go through and
you're like okay I'm interested in
education and science and parenting or
whatever and then all the articles that
have been published recently that fall
under those topics populate a feed on
the tab so that's the active component
you're telling us your interests we can
use those as input to generating the
feed and also as input to algorithmic
recommendations so there are multiple
uses of passive personalization on this
tab as well first of all we just order
this feed algorithmically and we also
include recommendations that are not
from these topics that you've said you'd
follow but we think that you'll like
them based on what you have expressed
interest in and the articles that you've
read in the past
then also there are a lot of topics you
can follow and so we recommend which
ones you might want to follow to make
the process easier so this this tab is
kind of fun to work on because it's new
its branded as a personalized space so
you can use it really as a playground to
try out different hypotheses of what
would engage with readers oh and if you
press Next then the video runs so this
parasite is scrolling through is a
separate set of recommendations just bit
separate from the feed so there are
different components in here and we're
actually adding things like basically
every month and so we also work on the
web on the home page and the article
pages on the home page we personalize a
block called smarter living this is a
feature reblock and the the way in which
we personalize content on these pages is
really a good example of how we work
together with the newsroom to to do
personalization because we want to make
sure that the articles we're
recommending are appropriate for the
place in which we're recommending them
and so the way that we do this is by
having the editors curate a large list
of articles that are appropriate for any
given spot for the smarter living block
or for this recirculation block on the
article page called editors picks and so
this is a large curated list of content
so it is in fact editors picks and then
we algorithmically choose which handful
of articles to show to each individual
based on what's popular at the time
based on the individuals reading history
and all of these things are very
successful they mean they left
engagement by you know multiple tens of
percents and also it ends up surfacing
many more articles than would be able to
be shown on the home
and article pages otherwise a fun
project which we launched recently and
which is another one that started as a
summer intern project is cooking arrests
a few recommendations so the cooking in
New Times comm website is very popular
and on all the recipe pages they have a
number of you know recirculation
components recommending other recipes
and so we took over recommending recipes
in this ribbon the recommendations are
based on similarity between the Cathy
recipes and the one that you're
currently on and also with a popularity
component to make sure you're getting
ones that are appealing and they look
really appealing and so this has been
really successful also and was another
place that we've been playing with
recently we have two emails that we
algorithmically curate one of them is a
weekly one's called your weekly edition
and one is brand new and in the middle
of rolling out now it's a daily one
called the for you daily email you can
sign up for any of these actually so
actually before going into how we do it
when I mentioned in the beginning that
we are a cross-functional team it listed
myself separately from the data
scientists because as the team lead I
have more of a product facing role and
what that means basically is that I
spend a lot of time in meetings talking
to people but it's really interesting
because I get to work with different
people on all these different types of
projects I mean these different slides
that I showed you about the different
surfaces tend to have different product
leads and so I'm really interesting part
of of this work is that we get to go
talk to these different parts of the
company and figure out where we can take
advantage of machine learning or improve
existing machine learning to increase
engagement on the different
and then we have to prioritize all of
this and and in the end make sure that
we're agreeing to do things that are not
impossible because often people want you
to do things that are really not
possible and also that we agree to do
them in a amount of time that's a
reasonable so how do we do it I mean
there are two pieces to this algorithms
and then the infrastructure which we use
to host those algorithms and serve the
recommendations the infrastructure is a
really big deal for us because we are a
user facing service you know we need to
be robust so first just a little bit
about our algos I mean we have more than
I'm showing but we have some go-to ones
and there are pretty standard things for
a you know recommendation team to be
using for we have some content
similarity algorithms to recommend
articles that are on topics that you
have read before um examples of this
include you know implementing this using
LD a or dr. Beck we also use
collaborative filtering which just uses
people's reading patterns it doesn't
care about what the articles are about
at all it just says that if you know
somebody has read articles a B and C
then if somebody else comes and has read
articles a and B you know then they
might enjoy articles see because people
who read articles a and B also like to
read articles see the implementation
we're using is also a pretty standard
one is als alternating least-squares our
most exciting algo that is a workhorse
of ours is our contextual bandit on this
small font link that's really long which
is why he's in small font across the
bottom is a blog post that
Coenen who's on our teams one of the
data scientists recently wrote on the x
open blog which is our developer blog
and it's all about the contextual
bandits and it's really interesting so
you should all read it but the idea well
the idea behind a multi-armed bandit is
that it's an efficient way of showing
popular content and so it well it's
under the circumstances where you have a
lot of new content coming in I mean we
publish content a lot and when the
articles are just published we don't
know how popular they are or are going
to be so the bandit is very efficient at
exploring these new articles and showing
new things while at the same time
usually showing the stuff that is most
popular so you do get a lot a large
click-through rate right now we're using
a pretty simple I love this it's linear
you see B um a contextual bandit takes
the multi-armed bandit and on top of
that includes some information based on
either the user or the articles that are
being recommended or both so for simple
cases of for example a bandit if you can
see that I'm reading from New York you
can show me what's popular with users in
New York and more interestingly you can
include context based on people's
reading history and recommend things
that are popular with users with similar
reading history all right so how do we
do it in terms of infrastructure I'm
going to go a little heavy on this part
but I think it's interesting this is a
simplified diagram of our recommendation
infrastructure or our infrastructures
real times so you know we have to
respond when people show up at the
website with recommendations and we've
designed this I mean I'm saying we this
is like the Royal we because most of
this was built before I actually joined
the team but we are in the middle of
on pretty much all of it actually so
it's always a work in progress we
designed this to try to make a system
that is very flexible in terms of adding
and developing new algorithms so there
are a few different pieces to this and
I'm going to talk through this with an
example because it's hard to know like
what's going on there are also a couple
things that I wanted to this actually
work it's not promising I'll point a
couple things that I wanted to point out
one is that we've pretty much separated
the model training and article scoring
part of the recommendation process from
the real time services that are in the
path of the user request so we have two
different languages here the blue dashed
line is around code that's all in go and
that all has to be real time has to be
very fast and so we use go because it's
very good with concurrency and the red
dashed line is around our algo training
service which is in Python and so this
is great because when you want to build
new models you can you know people tend
to try things out in Jupiter notebooks
you know everybody uses Python libraries
all over the place and this means that
we can continue using these same
libraries and the same code that you
test it locally and use them to train
models that are used in production and
this training is all done in bet
sometimes fast batch so I wanted to go
through an example here to make it a
little more concrete for the case of the
content similarity recommendations using
Lda so again this is recommending
articles on topic similar to articles
that you've read before it's pretty
standard thing to do first I want to
talk about the red bit about training
the algos so I mean this you should
probably sound pretty familiar you know
you want to train your Lda model on a
bunch of you know somewhat recent
articles so once a day we have a job
that uses standard Python libraries like
an L TK and scikit-learn
to train an Lda topic model and this
model is saved as a pickle to Google
cloud services one thing that I did not
mention actually is that all of this
stuff is hosted on Google Cloud it's all
on a Koopa nerdy's cluster we use
various Google services for storing and
query our data like Google Cloud you
know just yes and a big table of
bigquery memory store so you might see
things like Google Cloud Storage in this
slides so then we have a trained topic
model we need to score all of the
articles on on a relatively frequent
basis so once an hour we score all our
articles this is the same code base as
the training job and the topic vector is
now particle are just saved to to memory
store so this is a key value store it's
it's that thing that says memory stored
Redis so it's a flexible and fast key
value store so that's basically it for
the algo integration part there's one
more very important piece but the next
step is for somebody to actually show up
on the web or in the app and need a
recommendation so what happens so our a
sort of gateway API called algo API is
the first thing that receives the
request it comes with the user ID and
sometimes something I lost over is how
we actually receive the set of articles
that are the candidate ones that we are
allowed to recommend from I will
continue to gloss over that and say that
we get it with the request which what
happens in certain cases we experiment
all the time and we want all of our
surfaces to be really a be test so that
we can learn about how our algorithms
are performing and figure out how to
improve
so one of the first things that the alga
API does is ask what you know figure out
what experiment variant that I am in and
then which algo that corresponds to and
then it descends that info to the
ranking service my user ID list of
articles Iago basically what the ranking
service does is it just fetches a lot of
information it needs to know my reading
history fetches that from our user
history service it needs to know the
topic vectors for all of those articles
that I've read fetches that from the
memory store that's the stuff that the
batch job saved you know within the last
hour and you need to combine those topic
vectors to get one single vector that
corresponds to my own reading history so
you can just average those if you want
to get like an average a topic vector
from my user history okay so now you
know about me you need to know about the
candidate articles as well so again
fetch the topic vectors for those
candidate articles and then there comes
the calculation part you need to take
all of these top effectors the one for
me the one for the candidates to figure
out what that means in terms of what you
should recommend so you need to figure
out the the recommendation scores for
all of these articles and in this case
you can just do cosine similarity
between my topic vector and each of the
candidate vectors then you just sort by
similarity and return so um that's
basically than the way that it works we
I said that we tried to make this as
easy as possible for developing new
algos and so if you want to develop a
new algo what you do is you basically
make just a new directory in the algo
ranking repo you put your code in there
to do whatever model training you want
and assign whatever kind of metadata
unique to each article and put that in
memory store this kind of separable
setup works for any case in which you
can generate recommendations based on
some article metadata that you calculate
offline which covers a lot of ground in
terms of types of algorithms that you
can do
then depending on what you're adding as
an algo you may or may not need to add
another ranker in the go code you can
sometimes reuse what we have already if
it's just simple you know scoring and
comparing numbers or you know you're
doing cosine similarity but if you're
using some sort of new custom algo you
might need to implement code in there to
really understand you know how to use
the metadata to generate scores and do
that in a efficient way because this is
part of the real-time service so I
mentioned at the beginning that we have
a cross-functional team I think one of
the really fun things about working on
this team in a cross-functional way is
that the data scientists get to a bright
production code and so you know we write
the not just the Python batch training
stuff but also the go ranking code and
it's a fun opportunity to like learn how
to do these things and also have better
habits you know like writing unit tests
around everything that you're writing
and making sure that it passes
integration tests and has you know good
code cleanliness and then also then you
get to see that the code that you've
wrote is actually serving
recommendations to readers of the times
which is which is really interesting um
so yeah I think I wanted to give you an
overall impression of the work that
we're doing and how we do it the some of
the most interesting parts for me have
been seeing how we can use and develop
an infrastructure that's both very
robust and allows for smooth machine
learning development and then also on
the product side it's been really
interesting to work with different parts
of the company to make sure that all of
this work that we're doing is actually
used effectively by the different
products at the times so thanks
[Applause]